parler du liban en direct de beyrouth
françois lebas chat économiste et
fondateur du site d'information
libnanews bonjour françois el bacha
merci de répondre à nos questions une
troisième conférence en douze mois lors
des précédentes 298 millions et 400
millions de dollars ont été promis
des gouttes d'eau au regard de la
situation que traverse le liban à quoi
s'attendre cette fois pour mercredi déjà
cette conférence va plutôt ternes être
la mise en place d'une aide directe la
population c'est à dire on va essayer de
court circuiter les structures de l'état
honda pas si on va essayer de passer par
l'armée libanaise et si on suit un peu
les recommandations de la commission
parlementaire de la défense en france on
doit passer par la banque mondiale et
par là et par l'onu en fait donc il
s'agit de court circuiter une
administration locale qui est considéré
comme corrompu et qui détournent des
fonds
mercredi marquera également un premier
anniversaire de la terrible explosion du
port de beyrouth qui a fait 200 morts
les libanais se prépare à descendre dans
la rue justement ce 4 août
un an après la catastrophe est ce qu'on
peut craindre des débordements alors que
se tiendra au même moment cette fameuse
conférence des donateurs
illfurth a craint qu'il y aura des
débordements effectivement la population
est fatiguée elle est fatiguée par
rapport au fait que un an après et
aucune justice qui n'a été donné aucun
élément aucune personnalité qui a été
mise en cause ni aucun progrès il ya le
parlement qui essayent de justement
manipuler les choses pour pour ne pas
mettre en cause d'anciens ministres qui
étaient à l'époque informées de la
présence du nitrate d'ammonium et qui
n'ont rien fait il ya beaucoup de
questions qui se posent qui sont restées
sans réponse et le match a donc
l'économie fin et fondateur du site
d'information à libnanews
on a vu cette semaine la pression de
paris de washington
pour des réformes sous peine de menaces
simple avertissement ou véritable
ultimatum
un jour il faudra bien y arriver
tout simplement parce que le système
étoilé bloqués ici localement donc pour
le moment c'est il essaie de trouver une
sorte de moyens pour contourner le
système public justement par l'aide
directe à la population via des
institutions par l'armée libanaise des
sourds de sécurité sans passer par
l'administration publique est gangrené
par la corruption
mais un jour ou l'autre il faudra quand
même bien cessé d'agiter des menaces et
passer aux actes justement on parle de
réformes à mener mais quelle réforme
exactement les réformes il ya plusieurs
pendant il ya même des réformes
économiques qui a un foyer de pertes
important qui est le l'électricité du
liban qui coûte à peu près entre 1
milliard 5 et 2 milliards de dollars par
an depuis 1997 mis à des réformes aussi
accomplir toujours du côté administratif
sur les doigts de libanaise on a vu le
fait que beaucoup de marchandises par
exemple sur le corps de beyrouth étaient
stockés depuis une dizaine d'années
parce que les gens refusaient de payer
entre guillemets des commissions mis à
la culture du bakchich en fait qui est
une forme de corruption au liban et il
s'agit aussi de mettre un terme à tout
cela
à vous les réformes monétaires aussi
vous disiez tout à l'heure que cette
nouvelle conférence des donateurs
va intervenir via un nouveau processus
en passant par l'armée la banque
mondiale pour essayer de contourner la
classe dirigeante corrompue selon vos
termes mais il ya un nouveau premier
ministre
quand même il s'appelle najib mikati est
ce qu'il peut être l'homme providentiel
qui est il exactement et surtout de quel
moyen at il bénéficié pour tenter de
sortir le pays de la crise najib mikati
est un homme qui pose un certain nombre
de problèmes s'il ya la fois il est très
impliqué dans le système monétaire
il a des actions dans les banques donc
le fait déjà de réformer le secteur
bancaire sera contre son intérêt il y
aura il ya des conflits d'intérêts
énorme à son sujet donc il ya beaucoup
d'interrogations sur sa marche réelle de
manoeuvre qu'elle soit voulue ou qu'est
ce qui sera imposée par la communauté
internationale en vue de débloquer les
fonds
donc personnellement je suis pas très
optimiste quant à un nouveau premier
ministre et sous à ces actions plus de
50% des libanais vivent aujourd'hui sous
le seuil de pauvreté
comment la population accueille telle
cette nouvelle conférence espoirs
indifférence méfiance lassitude ne
connais pas les détails il est très peu
syndiqués sur la conférence elle-même
elle est beaucoup plus impliqué sur la
commémoration qui a eu lieu le même jour
de l'explosion du 4 août
en fait donc c'est quelque chose qui est
beaucoup plus important pour elle et il
y aura effectivement je pense comme je
l'aï dit tout à l'heure des incidents
parce que on ne voit pas les enquêtes se
poursuivent de manière à mettre en cause
des personnalités politiques
merci françois paychère d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes économiste et fondateur du site
d'information libnanews